ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا
العميد الياس لاحظنا في الاونه الاخيره
تزايد في وتيره العمليات داخل العمق
الروسي الى اي مداه هي مقلقه فعلا لروسيا
جمال بالمعنى العسكري والاستراتيجي ليست
مقلقه الى حد ما ولكنها تخدم هدف معين
للقوات الروسيه للقوات الاوكرانيه او
للخطه الاوكرانيه الهدف منها تشتيت الداخل
على ان الامن القومي الروسي والامن في
الداخل الروسي ليس مؤمنا ضرب صوره الرئيس
بوتين وبالتالي الزام القوات الروسيه التي
قد تستعمل في مكان ما لصد الهجوم
الاوكراني المرتقب ان تثبت في هذه الامكنه
وهذا امر مهم جدا وهي عمليه ما يسمى
بالقعقعه في مكان ما بهدف الخداع وبالتالي
التركيز على مكان ما قد يكون فيه يعني
الهجوم الاوكراني المنتظر المنتظر يعني
سمعنا كثير بان هذا الهجوم المرتقب سيكون
قريبا او ولكن لم يتم حتى هذه اللحظه
لماذا يعني اليوم يجب ان يكون هناك جهزيه
عسكريه هناك ما يقارب بين التسعه و11 لواء
يدرب خارج اوكرانيا اصبح جاهزا
ان يكون هناك جهزيه للسلاح نتحدث عن
دبابات نتحدث عن صواريخ جديده
كما اتى من بريطانيا نتحدث عن طلبات كثيره
نتحدث عن الاف 16 وعن الجهوزيه الجويه هذا
الامر جمال يتطلب جهد كبير وقت وقت وجهد
كبير يعني عندما تقول هجوم يجب ان يكون
هناك قتال مشترك او كومباين كما يقال يعني
الدبابه تعمل مع المدفعيه مع الهندسه لنزع
الالغام لزرع الاغام مع الطائرات وبالتالي
مع دفاعات جويه وهذا امر يستلزم وقت
ويستلزم خبره معينه وهذا الامر كله ليس
بالضروره ان يكون في جبهه معينه قد يكون
في عده جبهات
وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه تقول بان نتلقى
الطلب من اوكرانيا لتسليم صواريخ الكروز
من طرازات
لا اعرف اذا كان الاسم صحيح
ايضا هناك في الطريق طائرات 16
ما اهميه يعني هذا السلاح في المعركه كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر على السير المعارك مع روسيا
في اوكرانيا الستور مشادو وصل 250 كم
اليوم هو ثلاث مرات اكثر من سلاح الهايمرز
يعني انت
اعتادت القوات الروسيه على الهايمرس وعدلت
التكتيكات الخاصه بها عندما تاتي بسلاح
يضرب عمق اكثر انت تضرب العمق الاساسي
خاصه اللوجستي انت تزرع الفوضى في خلفيه
الجيش الروسي اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
التوروس هو لم يصل هو طلب وعندما نتحدث عن
اف 16 لا زال في بدايه الطريق في
التدريبات فاذا قد يكون هذه الاسلحه جمال
لمرحله ما بعد وقف العمليات العسكريه
ويهدف الى حمايه ما تبقى من اوكرانيا اذا
صح التعبير للمرحله القادمه على ان تكون
من ضمن حلف النيتو ولكن ليس في علم النيتو
وهذا الامر بدا بالحديث عنه في
بين الدول المنضويه لحلف الناتو الوقت
نفسه روسيا تدعي بانها نفتت اليوم
حواليتين وثمانين
طلعه لضرب مواقع في اوكرانيا ونقتلت 500
جندي اوكرانيا الى اي مدى الطبيعه هذه
البيانات صحيحه ان كانت تصدر من روسيا او
من اوكرانيا اليوم الى جانب الحرب التي
تدور في المعركه في مخموت في الدفكا في
كريمينا هناك حرب اعلاميه ايضا جمال هناك
الانفورميشن كما يقال هناك حرب اعلاميه
للتاثير على الراي العام الداخلي وحتى
الخارجي وحتى للخداع للفريقين في هذه
الحرب
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا لك على
الافاده